[Music]
hey everybody just a quick update video
here it seems like Avengers infinity war
is doing insanely well in China right
now while Avengers infinity war has
almost hit two billion dollars worldwide
in China it has earned 2.2 billion yen
that converts to 343 million u.s.
dollars and is a huge benchmark for
Marvel and China to celebrate Marvel
China released this new poster for
Avengers infinity war that teases
Captain Marvel it's kind of interesting
that they would put this in credit scene
spoiler on a new poster but maybe
they're just prepping people for the
arrival of Captain Marvel herself
Captain Marvel is said to be a huge
power hitter in Avengers 4 and a key to
defeating Thanos so it would make sense
that they would hyper up Captain Marvel
will appear in her own solo movie in
March of 2019
right before she teams up with the
Avengers to fight Thanos in Avengers 4
what do you all think about this new
Avengers infinity war poster and the
huge end credits scene Captain Marvel
spoiler on it ultimately it does not
spoil anything about the actual movie
just the end credits scene but still let
me know your thoughts and let me know if
you are excited to see Captain Marvel
and March of next year also don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]